thank you thank you Mr President
[Applause]
whether you wandered here aimlessly or
whether you're intentionally here it is
the year 2023 this is our first show
it's January 2nd I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report we're live streaming
on Rumble and YouTube Share And
subscribe if you have not
and I hope more than anything else you
guys had a great Christmas break I hope
everybody's feeling refreshed after the
new year you know everyone thought 2020
was the crazy year remember when 2021
rolled in and everyone was like well we
got 20 20 behind us and then 2021 came
in 2021 was nuts and then 2022 came and
2022 was bananas well we are now in 2023
and I think or at the very least it will
be my mission to make 2023 a little more
sane than what we've been going through
for the last three years because
everyone seems like they've completely
lost their mind I think that if you
watch this show you're in what I would
call the semi-sane lane sure you have
your issues you're working on it okay we
could all better ourselves myself
included but you're like kind of roughly
sane but the world is just going to keep
spinning out of control that's just how
it is and I think the challenge for the
uh roughly the semi-sane is to pick up
whatever pieces we can build some things
whether it's families or institutions or
communities or whatever else to like
really have something that's ours as
everyone else goes bananas and that
really is going to be my theme for this
year and everything we're doing going
forward and uh and I just want to say
I'm I'm really excited to be back in
studio you know I had a great week we
had a lot of family here my parents were
here my brother was here with his three
kids my sister visited with her three
kids like we did the family food thing
the food thing the drinking thing the
partying thing all of the stuff uh and
it's it's always a nice way to end the
year and then and then you come back and
hopefully you're refreshed and ready to
take on uh the new year and that's kind
of how I'm feeling are we all feeling
that today we're all we gotta go all
right I got very consistent head nods
everyone in this room is ready to take
on the world are you people that really
is the question before we get to the
meat of the show I do want to get uh one
fun cool uh kind of
interesting announcement that I've been
working on for quite some time I want to
address it real quick so as you guys
know we have been part of the blaze
Network for the last couple years that
they've been helping us on our ad sales
side and I do some stuff with Glenn and
the team over there and I absolutely
love everybody over there but at the
same time I did create locals a couple
years ago and the idea of course of
locals was to create
Community
Based answers to all of the big Tech
problems a place where you could have
sort of
uh close closed conversation let's say
like subscriber based conversation where
we could get things out to you guys
without ads all of those things and we
did that and then eventually over the
last year we joined forces with Rumble
and we really are building those
alternative uh pipes to the Internet so
starting today we're really doubling
down on our Rumble and locals uh
exclusive package let's say that's what
we're going to be doing going forward so
there are going to be some some changes
around here first off let me just say
this I love everybody at the blaze we
are working on a license agreement with
them to so that they will still get the
show uh so and you're some of you are
watching this on the blaze right now
we're actually we ended the contract
with them but because there is no
tension we're trying to figure out a few
things so you can still watch on the
blaze right now so right now nothing has
changed if you're if you're a blaze
subscriber so you're good to go but we
will be doubling down on everything
we're doing with Rumble and locals and
starting today instead of doing locals
questions at the end of the show which
is normally what we do where I take you
know three or four questions or comments
things throughout the show we're going
to do a 10 or 15 minute post game show
exclusively on locals at the end of
every show so that'll be a little more
relaxed a little more recap of what
we've done if I screwed things up if
you've got questions if you want to get
personal all of that stuff will be on
locals after I'm sure there'll be many
questions related to this and and the
answers are still coming and just one
more time to be absolutely completely
clear we're working on the license deal
with the blaze guys I love absolutely
everybody over there there was no
tension no anger no nothing there was no
no problem whatsoever it was just purely
obviously at this point I put so much
into what I have what I've been building
with locals in Rumble and I really felt
that that was sort of the way we got to
go I know some of this is a little bit
under the hood stuff but anyway there is
that and we shall see what happens uh
what I want to focus on though for the
for the start of of the show today is
that as I'm sure pretty much all of you
have heard
broadcasting Legend Barbara Walters
passed away over the last couple days at
the age of 93. and you know I've
actually been an admirer of Barbara's
pretty much forever I mean I literally
remember probably late 80s like when I
was 12 or 13 years old watching her
interviews and watching her
do her thing and and talking to all of
these people and traveling all over the
world then of course creating the view
and everything else uh and I I think
Barbara's uh trajectory as a person or
at least politically from what you could
tell because sometimes it was hard to
tell what her opinions were but then
you'd get these little glimmers where
you could really see it she really was
an old school liberal she believed in
conversation as a as an interviewer she
really tried to bring together a diverse
set of viewpoints on The View that was
the initial point of the view to bring
together these people who look
differently and thought differently and
to be able to sit at a table and respect
each other and have conversations so she
was an old school liberal in that regard
and I think her passing and maybe her
passing really as the year came to a
close was uh was sort of a metaphor for
what's going on in America right now
because we don't have as you know those
liberals anymore there's there's a
couple people trying to wave that flag
and I I certainly was one of them for a
long time and I think in a in a sort of
perfect world that doesn't exist I still
could be one of those people to to some
extent
um but with her gone I think there
really is a a way that we can look at
the media now and really see how out of
control it got just by looking back at a
little bit of her career so that's what
I'm going to frame most of the show on
today and uh I think they're going to
dig it that's my feeling about that so
let's uh let's start off with this quote
from Thomas Soul because a couple days
ago I was trying when I was thinking
about when we come back how I want to
frame the show this was before Barbara
passed away I'm trying to think I want
like a quote or is there a great video
or something that really could frame
what we want to do here going forward
for 2023 and we we found this great
quote from the Fantastic there isn't
even an adjective to describe him Thomas
so people will forgive you for being
wrong but they will never forgive you
for being right especially if events
prove your right while proving them
wrong
me because that kind of hit it on the
head right like think of the things of
the last couple years whether it was the
hunter Biden laptop in Russia collusion
and Brett Kavanaugh is a serial rapist
and I know you guys know the list Jesse
Smollett and all of these things all of
the covid stuff all of the censorship
related to Big Tech uh Donald Trump very
fine people on both sides all of these
things there were some people who viewed
those things with a skeptical eye some
people who did not fall and completely
buy Russia collusion or That vaccine
mandates were were what was going to
save us or some of those things I think
on the big issues
this is a little self-inflating I
suppose for me to say but on the on the
big issues I've basically been on the
right side of things uh I've made some
wrong moves along the way right some
wrong predictions I would say uh I
really thought the Red Wave was coming
it didn't it didn't fully materialize
obviously but there's a difference
between sort of getting the big stuff
right and then like the the racehorse
politics part of the stuff wrong and I
think the position we're in which is the
reason that I wanted to throw that that
quote up the position we're in right now
is well all of these people who got so
much wrong who then injected their kids
with stuff who forced doctors and nurses
who were at first non-essential to then
be fired none of these people have been
fired now fauci's out right so today is
technically day one as January you know
it's the first Monday of the year of
fauci no longer being in government he's
been in government for 40 years that's
good but wolenskies still run in the CDC
nobody got fired at Pfizer or moderna
for pushing vaccines that have all sorts
of side effects and that aren't as
effective as they were promised to be so
many people in our political machine in
our in our media machine they got it's
not just that they got these things
wrong it's it's that they were they were
using using these things to bludgeon
those of us who believed in choice and
and Liberty and the way I would connect
that to to sort of Barbara Walters is
the ideas of Liberty and discussion and
not forcing people to do things those
were once liberal ideas right those that
was the core actually of liberalism
right I might not agree with what you
say but I will defend with my life your
ability to say it the ACLU in the early
70s defending the rights of Nazis to
march in Skokie Illinois a place that
had more Holocaust Survivors than any
other place in the United States because
as long as they did it non-violently
they could exercise their free speech as
could the people who wanted to then
counter protest them and everything else
so there used to be these people like
Barbara Walters there used to be well
there still is a Bill Maher type person
and there are some others that are kind
of there and I think as you know the
question is can you ultimately take your
ideas and then vote for people that will
defend those ideas or do you always end
up voting the wrong way and I think this
is all related to some of uh what
Barbara's career was all about but
before we get to the barber stuff I want
to show you a clip Bill Maher had Mark
Cuban on his podcast this past week and
of course Mark Cuban he's a tech he's
got to be he's got to be a billionaire
right he's a billionaire with a B uh and
uh and he's on Shark Tank and he owns
the Dallas Mavericks and he's fairly
outspoken I think he probably considers
himself to be a liberal and he's got
like a little bit of the woke stuff in
him anyway he and Bill Maher sat down
and they talked about the difference
between woke and liberal I think it's a
it's an interesting little bite you guys
don't get it woke and liberal are two
different things they're very often the
[ __ ] opposite of each other yeah so
don't lump and then be like anybody to
the right of woke is a concern no
no people just want to live Freedom
should be a liberal thing the word is
that's what Libra means free free right
and look we can have different attitudes
but just the idea of people getting
classified as woke or non-work or
conservative we don't talk about ideas
anymore we don't talk about Solutions
anymore we talk about categories
it's interesting the the Cuban portion
of it first we don't talk about ideas
anymore we just label people I mean we
talk about ideas here I don't know what
he means by we exactly right if he means
mainstream media corporate press the
machine that and I don't mean this to
attack Mark even I think he's probably a
decent guy he's made some mistakes along
the way we've we've communicated on
Twitter every now and again
um but like there are plenty of people
talking about ideas right there really
are it's just not the machine people
talking about ideas the machine people
are the ones that want to mandate people
to do things the machine people the
corporate people are the ones who want
to say if you don't believe this the
moment we believe it you're a racist and
a big and a homophobe and you're
anti-science and all of those things but
I wrote a couple books about ideas I
tried to do that on this show every day
I'm certainly not the only one doing
that you could flick on Shapiro or
Crowder or a whole bunch of other people
or have you heard of this Jordan
Peterson guy I'm pretty sure he talks
about ideas all the time so it is
happening but it isn't it just hasn't
really fully bubbled up to that
mainstream layer and I don't know how
important that mainstream layer is
anymore so it's interesting when Bill
Maher says Freedom should be a liberal
thing well of course he's right Freedom
should be a liberal thing liberals
should constantly be defending freedom
of speech and freedom of Association and
all of those things and making sure that
the government is not infringing on your
Free Speech but liberals don't really do
that you guys know my feelings about you
know sort of the Divergence let's say
that that Bill Maher and I have had
um and I I think it's a lofty goal what
he's trying to do to still wave that
flag and say hey we liberals have to act
liberally we have to silence the vote
that that is a lofty goal I don't think
it can be done from the political
position which he's in which is sort of
why two or three days before the midterm
elections Bill Maher was making the
rounds on television telling people to
vote for Democrats to save democracy
I just think he's mistaken with that
right so that's that's different but the
point is that bill and I can have that
conversation so now I want to bring this
to Barbara Walters uh because Barbara
Walters really was someone who was
trying to do this and and for those of
you that are on the more conservative
side that are watching this going well I
didn't like what Barbara Walters did
with the view or anything else you have
to sort of take someone's life in the
time that they lived and in the time
that she lived especially for you know
those 30 or 40 years when she was she
was a Mainstay of American culture and
politics and everything else she really
was someone that was trying to talk to
all sorts of people which again once was
a liberal position but just here's a
little bit more on her passing from the
daily wire Barbara Walters a journalist
at ABC News who helped Forge the way for
women to appear on news broadcasts has
died she was 93 years old ABC News broke
the story on her death but provided no
details or any statements from her
family so I suppose we'll find out a
little bit more about how she passed at
93 years old it really doesn't matter at
this point but she has a legacy to be
very very proud of and also you know I
don't really care about the the identity
politics version of this but she was a
true Trailblazer not only just as a
journalist
but as a woman like now women do
everything and that's great if that's
what they want to do it's just great and
I don't care if an interviewer is black
or white or male or female or gay or
straight or anything else but she really
was in essence the first mainstream
woman interviewing heads of state and
states and popes and going everywhere
and doing absolutely everything and
getting it to the place that it became
normalized and we should give credit to
the people that do that uh here's a
little compilation of some of some of
Barbara's work over the years this is
just a random collection that we put
together and you know She interviewed
everybody it was celebrities and reality
TV people to literally the pope and the
president here's just a little bite
famous you don't really act you don't
sing you don't dance you don't have any
forgive me any Talent Nikki recently
released a song it's called hell yeah
it's about American Idol and she says
I'm quick to check a [ __ ] if she is out
of line
are you the [ __ ]
she's singing about
don't know
don't know what she's saying I didn't
know she sang I thought she wrapped or
whatever I'm sitting opposite you
that you are a little overweight more
than a little yeah yeah
why
well if I could figure that out I'd fix
it do you try to diet well Barbara I've
had I've had more diets and lost and
gained back more weight in my lifetime
than I care to count there are people
who say that you couldn't be president
because you're so heavy what do you say
to them no it's ridiculous
folks okay you want that same guy
Elizabeth calm down
everybody has strong opinions and there
are many other arguments that other
people could give you I think the most
important thing which is what we see
today is we've got to be able to have
these discussions and listen to other
people's opinions and not those how
crazy that you don't listen I heard
everything you said I just am emphatic I
barely started well and it's not just my
opinion
did there at the end so look we could
have picked a zillion questions whether
she was interviewing Bill Clinton or
Barack Obama or literally the pope or
whoever we picked a couple that were a
little more in the culture thing but
like to say to the Kardashians to
literally sit down with the Kardashians
and be like you have no Talent like she
did that to say to sit down with Chris
Christie you're fat to do that like she
really was putting herself out there and
trying to have difficult conversations
like the Christie one is interesting
because it's like everyone kind of knows
it like he was never going to be
president but and it had something to do
with his weight right and she called him
out on that like that just is uh to the
Kardashians you've become this cultural
Force you do nothing that's interesting
uh but really at the end there is the
one that that it really is all about
where she says everyone has their own
opinions and in essence we have to be
able to talk about these things at the
very table of the show that she created
she created The View can you give me the
year on The View what what year did The
View come out about 25 years ago I think
or so uh and when she created it the
whole idea of the view as I said earlier
was to create this this place for women
in this case of all different walks of
life to come together and do it
respectfully it came out in 1997 25
years that's uh that's pretty good
about 26 years ago
um but she did that and she tried to
maintain some level of let's let's have
these conversations to the best of our
ability it's the most American thing you
can do now we're going to get to more on
or well let's just keep going with this
for just a second so unfortunately over
the course of the 25 years of the view
it did devolve and I think uh that
really is is what I'm trying to show you
here that she set out to do something
really good and then the culture just
got so crazy and you could see her
warning Elizabeth Hasselbeck and by the
way Elizabeth Hasselbeck who have really
I don't know what she does these days
but I came to really respect her over
the years I was definitely a lefty and a
liberal when I was watching The View
years ago and she was a conservative so
I disagreed with her a lot but there as
Barbara saying to her we got to kind of
sit there and be able to have these
conversations Elizabeth really learned
how to do that on The View and she
really did it quite well but but the
view now here's the the point I play a
lot of clips of The View right and when
we play the clips with you it's like
they've become the worst sort of
shrieking harpies judgmental politically
polarizing using all of the baseless
accusations of racism and everything
else and there are moments over the
years of the view that it really did
collapse and one of them happened while
Barbara was sitting there you may
remember this this is about 10 years ago
or so uh maybe a little bit less do we
know it's about 10 years ago
yeah around 10 years ago Bill O'Reilly
was on The View and they started talking
about 9 11 and watch what happened here
[Applause]
oh my God
Muslims didn't kill us on 9 11. is that
what you said yeah
[Applause]
actually about 12 13 years ago in 2010 I
don't want to get too lost in the
conversation that they were having I
would just say Bill Bill O'Reilly
floppily laid that out you cannot blame
all Muslims for the actions of some
Muslims you can't blame all Jews for the
actions of some Jews etc etc right that
is collectivism but my point of that was
not to to get into the specifics of what
they were talking about it was to show
that this this show that existed to have
people on to have decent conversations
it devolved and I think that really is a
metaphor for so many of the things
happening right now uh now here's what
happened right after that and uh this is
Barbara at her best
I want to say something
I want to say something to all of you
you had just seen what should not happen
we should be able to have discussions
without washing our hands and screaming
and walking off stage I love my
colleagues it could not have happened
I am I'm glad that the view audience
applauded for her there now the audience
did not applaud as loudly as they did
when joy and Whoopi walked off but now
if you take
all the times that I now make fun of joy
and Whoopi and you look back on that and
you go man they could have tried to have
a very difficult conversation there why
couldn't Joy or Whoopi have said you
know when you say this about all Muslims
that sounds bigoted you can blame these
specific people we can talk about the
doctrine of religions and how people get
radicalized and all those things but
they couldn't do it and again that's not
to defend the specifics of what Bill
O'Reilly is saying but the point is that
at that time in 2010 Bill O'Reilly was
the number one person in the history of
cable news he's since left Fox obviously
and Tucker now is the number one guy in
cable news but he was the number one
personality on cable news so the number
one guy basically bringing news to the
masses he then sits down with these
ladies and they walk away like if that's
not indicative of what is going on here
with jerk journalism and with media and
all of the stuff and then Barbara did
the right thing Barbara did absolutely
the right thing and you can tell oh that
was not planned right maybe joy and
Whoopi had a plan to to do whatever they
were to do but that Barbara immediately
that is not what you do here calling out
her colleagues in essence her employees
she was the executive producer of the
show that is what we should all be
fighting for and unfortunately Clips
like that then go viral and more and
more people get emboldened to not have
conversations more and more people get
involved into just say you're a racist I
ain't gonna have anything to do with it
but unfortunately what has happened the
voice that Barbara is expressing there
of conversation and let's work through
this difficult stuff is really no longer
there and when that disappears what do
you get you get a whole bunch of people
calling for censorship and that's what
we have right now in our media and our
political establishment so now let's
Flash Forward to literally yesterday uh
Amy Klobuchar who of course was running
for president as a Democrat a couple
years ago she's largely become
irrelevant but she's still she's still
hanging around round she was on Meet the
Press with Chuck Todd now Chuck Todd is
obviously a Democrat he is a Democrat
activist pretending to be a journalist
and here they are talking about
censorship and big Tech and what we
should do about all of you people who
say things that they don't like would it
look let's be realistic the the tobacco
companies changed after being hit with
Hefty lawsuits more than government
regulation after the lawsuits came more
government regulation do you think if
you open these company up companies up
to lawsuits and by the way Facebook's
being sued overseas for what it what its
role in um in an Ethiopian Civil War and
some other places
um do you think their behavior would
change yes because then in order to
continue they have to put safety
measures in place instead of sending out
sweet little notes about all the good
work they're doing they would actually
have to do something
how these guys actually act in cahoots
the way he frames the question comparing
big tech companies who don't do what he
wants which is silence you to Tobacco
companies that's the danger now tobacco
companies knowingly were killing people
everyone knew that nicotine was
addictive they knew that they were
putting all sorts of other chemicals in
there and they knew how many people were
dying of emphysema or lung cancer etc
etc and they had all this junk science
and all these people that they would put
on these shows to lie about it and
everything else comparing that to Big
tech companies and I'm not defending big
tech companies but their their argument
is Big tech companies are not doing
enough to silence you this is it's such
a crazy jump in logic but he frames it
that way and that's just perfect for her
to say ah if they don't do what we want
then we're going to start suing them
into Oblivion or we'll break them up or
we'll send Regulators in there or God
knows what so you have a giant news
organization NBC News calling for the
Silence of people and why would they do
that because they want them properly on
information right Chuck Todd does not
want I don't know Chuck Todd but Chuck
Todd does not want you watching the
Reuben report right Chuck Dodd doesn't
want you thinking about things that are
outside of the window of the things that
he wants you to think about right of
course not of course not right he wants
people to to believe in his worldview
and watch that I would like if more
people believed in my world view but I'm
not out there trying to censor other
people and of course the really
interesting part about that is what they
keep telling you they're worried about
is misinformation and disinformation but
if we were to go through the Litany of
things that Chuck Todd and NBC News at
CNN in Washington posted everywhere else
has lied about over the last couple
years they would all be banning
themselves and suing themselves into
Oblivion and much more I could have
shown you 400
000 roughly compilations of media lying
about things and demonizing people and
everything else but we got this one it
mostly focuses on the uh the Canadian
truckers you may remember them
Ottawa is being besieged by a group of
anti-doo anything about covid truckers
called the freedom Convoy a so-called
Freedom Convoy so-called Freedom Convoy
of truckers the police chief is calling
it a Nationwide Insurrection driven by
Madness this city is under siege they
are now calling it an occupation a
threat to democracy an Insurrection
sedition sedition Insurrection a threat
to democracy we've heard it called a
nationwide Insurrection this is kind of
our Insurrection by air horn moment I
think it's part of the globalization of
trumpism yes
a a cult yes it is residents say they
feel like hostages there hasn't been as
much violence as some had perhaps
projected but that does not necessarily
mean that it has been peaceful alarming
situation there in Ottawa they will have
to call a black woman Justice in America
she's going to be sitting there as a
woman in her black skin in a black robe
on the highest court in the land finally
there'll be people going in front of the
the court looking like me
and seeing someone that looks like them
to all the colored girls who considered
shaping Justice when this system was not
enough this moment is ours let me just
go ahead and speak for all black women
in America today saying we are extremely
proud this was a step towards the court
actually looking like a reflection of
the country it oversees
so the third the first part of that
obviously was the truckers and the way
that they frame the truckers right
they're all racist and bigoted and they
remember Justin Trudeau literally called
them transphobes that's why he said they
were out on the street what's also
interesting did you notice a couple
times those uh journalists called it the
so-called Freedom Convoy it was called
the freedom Convoy the freedom Convoy
people called it the freedom Convoy uh
but however when we had this don't say
gay thing here which was not called
don't say gay right it was hb1887 or
something like that uh no one called it
the so-called don't say gay they just
labeled it this the don't say gay so
these little tricks that that they do
that is that is so important for you to
be able to see and then of course the
reason that we showed you the katanji
brown Jackson stuff after was that so
much of the framing about her becoming a
Supreme Court Justice and being
nominated in the first place had nothing
to do with her qualifications it was
great to see a black woman but that in
and of itself it doesn't make you worthy
of being a Supreme Court Justice this is
literally a woman who could not Define
what a woman is so who Am I who am I to
say what a woman is when I describe her
it's very confusing uh but there are
some people in journalism still trying
there are one of them is one of the
people that I think is is the most
interesting in in politics or media
right now which is Tulsi gabbard again
who is a you guys know this she was a
Democrat a progressive a lefty her
entire life she has now at least left
the Democrat Party she goes on Tucker a
lot she's hanging out with you know
crazy right-wingers like Dave Rubin and
she has been guest hosting for Tucker
and she had on just over the last couple
of days there is a republican
Congressman newly elected Republican
Congressman George Santos and you may
have heard about this story it has now
turned out as he has been elected so he
won he is now a congressional freshman
uh it is turning out that his entire
resume is a lie not only the places that
he worked but he pretended that he had
family members who I think were
Holocaust Survivors then I think he said
he was gay but it turned out he was
married to a woman like it's so it's
like such a crazy ridiculous story
anyway Tulsi guest hosting for Tucker
had him on and did what Barbara Walters
did did she asked the tough questions
you don't really seem to be taking this
seriously you've apologized you said
you've made mistakes but you've outright
lie a lie is not an embellishment on a
resume you said you worked at Goldman
Sachs and Citigroup but they've said
we've got no record of this guy working
for us you've said you've gone to and
graduated from these universities but
they've said well we've got no record of
that these are blatant lies and it calls
into question how your constituents and
the American people can believe anything
that you may say when you are standing
on the floor of the House of
Representatives supposedly fighting for
them that's the real issue here
well look I and I I agree with what
you're saying and as I stated and I
continue
we can debate my my resume and how I
worked with firms such as is it
debatable or is it just false
no it's debatable or is it debatable I
no no it's not false at all it's it's
debatable I can I can sit down and
explain to you what you can do in
private equity in in capital intro via
servicing limited partners and general
partners and we can have this discussion
that's going to go way above the
American people's head but that's not
what I campaigned on I campaigned on
delivering results for the American
people by lowering inflation I can sit
down and if you want to have that
discussion I'd be glad to Tulsi to
explain that to you and make sure that
we we settled the score
that this is not about settling scores
and I think you just you just kind of
highlighted I think my concern the
concern that people at home have you're
saying that this discussion will go way
above the heads of the American people
basically insulting their intelligence
yeah
you see what we did here with the barber
thing there are some people trying to do
something kind of decent and I think
they have to be credited when they do
that I actually don't even want to make
this about this Santos guy and it's to
some degree I don't even care that he
lied about his resume people lie about
all sorts of things now I would prefer
that they did not but the media now the
rest of the media which is not
interviewing him which is just talking
about him is saying he has to step down
and how could he lie and oh my God lying
is so bad again I don't like lying but
if only they had ever asked questions
about another guy who lies alive because
there's this guy who's always stumbling
and fumbling around do you know who I'm
talking about and he's always kind of
like wandering and saying crazy things
and pretty much lying about everything
uh I I I got raised in the black church
he knows that I'm not kidding I got my
education
for real in the black church and that's
not hyperbole it's a fact I probably uh
went to school more than many of you did
you all think I'm kidding he can tell
you
I was sort of raised in the Puerto Rican
community at home politically I just
have one thing to say
thank you
all right
there you go
I assure you we could have shown you
many many other moments of Joe Biden
lying if you get the vaccine you will
not get nor transmit covid how about
that one
um all the times that he called Donald
Trump racist everything else he grew up
in the black church he was going to shul
all the time the guy's playing despacito
I mean he's everything he's a
shape-shifter whatever you want him to
be he can be but the media as you know
of course if Democrats lie you don't get
called out on that actually what they do
is they protect you so if there's a
hunter by the laptop story we're not
going to talk about that because that's
misinformation but if we can find one
random Republican who lied about a bunch
of stuff and again I'm not defending him
for doing it that guy is where we have
to focus all of our energy so what do we
need as I do this show the very first
show in January of 2023 we need a better
and healthier media but you know what
we're not gonna get it from the
corporate press there will be little
glimmers like what I just showed you
there from Tulsi that will still have
that spirit of what Barbara Walters
tried to create a long time ago there
will be these people that will try to
have difficult conversations I will
continue to do that I promise you guys
one of my main goals this year will be
to have more counter voices on the show
I will gladly do it I will really really
gladly do it I used to do it more and
then what would happen was I would get
an insane amount of hate usually from
people on the left for having talked to
someone on the right that when I was a
lefty and then it flipped eventually
right so it's like I will keep trying to
do it
but we need a better media I I'm not
bullish on that idea and we need better
political leaders and it's hard to get
good political leaders because the media
is so biased because the culture has
gotten so rotten good decent people
don't want to get involved and I mean
that at the citizen level and I mean it
at the political level but every now and
again some people step up one of those
people who has stepped up is the creator
of the libs of tick tock Twitter account
her name is Haya raychik people did not
know her name for a long time as you
know she was suspended by Twitter many
times when the Twitter files came out
she was one of the accounts that was
repeatedly suspended and banned and they
never had a specific reason why all this
girl does is she finds these crazy
gender activists who are often
Elementary School teachers she finds
their Tick Tock videos of how they're
indoctrinating kids and then she reposts
them often without comment so she's just
taking their their stuff and showing it
to other people but for showing what
they're saying themselves she has been
called a homophobe and a transform and a
racist and everything else but she is
someone who stepped up in the middle of
this insane culture War she got involved
and then when she stepped up somebody
else who I've talked about once or twice
on this show decided to help her out uh
here she is with Tucker Carlson just a
couple days ago talking about just that
someone from Rhonda Santos's team calls
me really yes and she said the governor
wanted me to give you a message he said
if you don't feel safe or you or your
family if you need a place to go to hide
to say you're you can come to the
governor's mansion what that we have the
guest house for you and you could come
and stay as long as you need
the governor of Florida yes I I can't
even I was like I was almost in tears
like the governor of Florida like he's
nothing but like and you're living I'm
living in California and he took time
out of his I'm assuming extremely busy
schedule you think I mean he's the
governor of Florida and to send someone
to call me to make sure I'm safe
you see what I'm saying this idea that
if you step up you can Inspire other
people to step up well that's just a
very granular example of that right
there she started doing the right thing
the media big Tech everybody went after
her the worst sort of hit pieces doxing
her all sorts of awful stuff and then
the governor of a state on the polar
opposite side of the country 3000 miles
away of which she is not a resident says
hey if you're in trouble we'll help you
out you'll be safe over here so that's
her stepping up it's him stepping up and
then what that also is is that other
people start seeing it and other people
get it in there get it they get it in
their pores like man you got to do some
things for yourself and guess what guys
you know it but it is happening at at
the most obvious level uh my buddy clay
Travis tweeted this out this is
absolutely fantastic uh some info uh
latest population numbers have been
released California's population
declined the most in 2020 2 while
Florida's grew the most Florida added
1200 people a day while California lost
600 people every day in 2022 that is
completely consistent by the way guys
with what's been going on there
California for the first time in 2020
lost population then the second time in
2021 and now the third time in 2022 and
all of those freedom-loving people who
just want the government off their back
who I have no doubt
in most cases they're not the most
staunch conservative people they're
usually liberals who have been mugged by
reality and who fortunately and the
proof is in the pudding by desantises
20-point win will now vote the right way
when they get here they are leaving
they're taking their resources their
lives their work their jobs their
friends their family and they're moving
into a place where freedom is is run and
rampant where literally the governor is
offering to give the guest house in
Tallahassee to someone who is fighting
for the right things and that is what is
happening here so I say all of that to
also tell you that tonight uh or right
after the show actually today I'm
heading on up to I'm jumping on a plane
I'm heading on up to Tallahassee because
uh Governor Ron DeSantis who won by 20
freaking points one of the biggest
landslides in American political history
who has turned Florida from purple into
deeply deeply red who led at the top of
the ticket to the point that Mark Rubio
who was expected to win absolutely crush
it Republicans have majorities a super
majority but majorities all over the
state right like this state is
functioning and working and we rebuild
Bridges and we're building houses fast
and everyone's moving here and Tech is
exploding and all of that stuff uh well
he is being inaugurated uh tomorrow so
there will be the inauguration in the
morning so I'm heading to that and then
there is a ball tomorrow evening there's
an event tonight and a bunch of other
things so I'm going to go I'm gonna I'm
gonna bring my trusty phone and I'll try
to get some video that we can post in a
bunch more but why did he get reelected
why was it because uh he's a he's some
sort of uh mean person who has tricked
people into voting for him or is it just
because uh he believes in Freedom and
that's what the people of Florida
believe in well you may remember this
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
aren't you glad to live in the Free
State of Florida
we are going to carry this torch of
Freedom onward because our mission is
very simple we are keeping the State of
Florida free thank you all God bless you
happens in America well when you care
about Freedom 1200 people a day move to
your state and they flee the states that
don't care about freedom and that's
because of the the OG Floridians who I
always like to credit whenever I give a
speech here in Florida I always say I
got to give some credit to you guys
Florida man used to be a meme you know
wrestling the alligator on a golf course
with a cigar in his mouth pulling a
puppy out of its jaws we used to make
fun of that guy but he did something
right and that's what's going on right
here in the State of Florida and and the
meat the the message of Freedom that is
happening here is something that I think
Florida will export I always call it the
blueprint for America but it's something
that I'm going to try to export
throughout 2023 and we are going to have
to fight right we're going to have to
fight the lies we're gonna have to fight
that corporate media we're going to keep
getting more of these Twitter file dumps
supposedly in the next couple days
there's going to be a fouchy related
Twitter file dump and more and more
people will find out what's true but the
machine will push back because it
doesn't want you to know that stuff
right it wants you to keep you at that
Chuck Todd NBC level of Truth where
you're just not getting the truth or
they're confusing you as to what the
issues are and all of that
um but we got a chance and that's why
I'm going to keep doing what I'm doing
it's also why I said at the top of the
show that we are doubling down on
everything we're doing with Rumble and
locals to ensure that that no one will
stop me from saying what I believe to be
true and making sure that you guys will
always be able to watch that
um so with that in mind the way we are
going to do the show going forward
normally this is the part of the show
where I'd be reading a couple comments
from the locals Community but what we
are doing going forward is that after
this show if you're watching on locals
right now you just keep watching
otherwise there is a link down below and
if you want to watch the post game show
where I'll do some questions it's just
going to be on the Fly no papers no
nothing some questions some comments the
guys can correct me if I butchered
anything whatever it might be that is
what we're going to do so the link for
that is right down below as I said if
you're watching on locals right now you
are good it's also Monday so we did a
little me Monday action over at the
locals Community this is the one I put
up it's dangerous to believe anything
blindly the science is settled that's
not how science Works you're a racist
that's the one I put up we got a whole
bunch of people putting on uh some other
ones so you can jump over right now we
are doing this right now there's going
to be like a minute break basically if
you're if you're watching you're going
to see a little bumper we're playing
some of this you know we're doing this
all on the Fly for the first time so
bear with us if there's any uh technical
hiccups and we'll continue that over
there and then just for just to be
totally clear
tomorrow's show I did pre-tape so we
won't do a post game show because I'm
going to be up with the governor and as
I said up at the inauguration as I said
I'm going to try to take some video and
some other things maybe we'll do some
live streams on locals and a bunch more
uh anyway happy 2023 guys our work is
cut out for us uh but I got nothing
better to do than save the world do you
let's find out
[Laughter]
I hope you have a wonderful Christmas
yeah I hope you guys have a wonderful
Christmas as well
let's go Brandon let's go Brandon I
agree
[Music]
foreign
[Music]